oubliez les vieilles expressions chef de
famille ou mademoiselle accorder les
titres grades et fonctions selon le sexe
en signant cette convention l'université
de versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
souhaite lutter contre les stéréotypes
caché dans sa communication qu'elle soit
écrite ou visuel c'est un sujet
extrêmement sensible qui touche les
étudiants qui touche les enseignants et
le personnel administratif de pouvoir
avoir lorsqu'on fait par exemple des
fiches d'emploi des fiches de poste
d'avoir candidate candidats candidate
vraiment de d'essayer de faire tout ce
qu'on a vu aujourd'hui c'est à dire de
faire attention à qui on de pages en ré
pour espérer combattre efficacement les
stéréotypes le haut conseil à l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes propose
au total la mise en place de dix
recommandations accord des métiers usage
du féminin et du masculin dans les
messages
pour la communication visuelle évitez
les couleurs douces pour les femmes et
les couleurs sombres pour les hommes du
bon sens pas encore des habitudes que
finalement le langage a été peu
questionné et on a peut questionner son
pouvoir sur les manières de penser et de
concevoir le monde sur les
représentations qu'on se fait des uns et
des autres et des unes et des autres
justement donc n'oublions pas dans
toutes les luttes qu'on a dans toutes
les démarches qu'on a pour promouvoir
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
de veiller à olemps gages qui est
utilisé en france seulement huit
universités se sont engagés en faveur de
cette convention
localement lu vs qu espère convaincre
certains de l'imiter